[Music]
yeah I've been questioning right now I'm
still questioning or I can't really tell
you if I do or not but okay that's
interesting because I think that there
was something some kind of creation of
somebody so you do you do you
acknowledge that well when I see both
sides I try to be open-minded so just
just to make you be more sure that there
is a creator
yes Moses we don't believe like for
example but is a object or God has a
bomb or a taco so we believe God is
Almighty
free from any means
he doesn't he's not in our creation
because anything that's in our tradition
is created yeah
so therefore so when it comes to you
believe this is the night it is designed
by the decide boys so why do you believe
this is design did you go and see the
Tiger mate it's what makes you complicit
design because everything that well all
the information all the creativity goes
through us we are designers of the
already designed but there has to be
something designed before her exactly so
when you look at this car and you see
the information you automatically use
your faculties your logic that
rationality and claim it's come come by
chance there must be somebody who made
it even though you did not see did you
see the man who made it did you see the
way they made it
do realize that even though he didn't
see them and even though he didn't sell
was made must be and the same thing
another example of giving with me is for
example in
if there's information it requires
intelligence right that's somebody so
when you go and read something that from
Angie knows that right cup coffee shop
you know that's information therefore
there has to be intelligence behind
again yeah you're looking to the DNA how
DNA works I know this code it's it's
within itself it's as you know language
and language that is operating it so if
there is information what did you say
information requires intelligence so
this information in the DNA
there should be so when we say we
believe that that's good alone and we
believe services know Quran say he is
one yeah
there is nothing like it yeah he does
not beget nor is it because yet so for
example we are talking Quran - go go -
move man
yeah yeah
so all buddies see or acknowledge me
please today but obviously that
something else what I say to it I need
to cooperate I don't hold you too much
into this code you girl show me some
style so what you do this here but
before easy before you do that here I
will see in a few days now in the Quran
give it a chance
I still have to read my Bible because
this work I came from the family of
I obviously do that I give this granular
chances walk yeah yeah seongjo you did
wanna read here and will you Joey's well
gain contact me maybe criticize together
yeah can you show some this is my leg
and you watch this is just
[Music]
we're gonna what you going into this
take this
you